well we have another disastrous example
of the repercussions of these horrifying
anti-abortion laws many of which were
triggered into existence
uh by the supreme court overturning roe
v wade we go to texas in texas a
youtuber
was forced to carry
her dead fetus
for two weeks after a miscarriage due to
the anti-abortion law
the same surgical procedure used to
treat a miscarriage is also used for
terminating pregnancies the new texas
anti-abortion laws have doctors nervous
to perform procedures for miscarriages
forcing this woman to carry her dead
fetus in her womb for two weeks
another example we've now seen women
going without emergency care
we've seen women going without cancer
care and now women forced to have their
dead fetus in the womb
for weeks due to these anti-abortion
laws and we're supposed to believe this
is all pro-life
beauty youtuber forced to carry dead
fetus for two weeks after miscarriage
due to abortion ban
i get so angry that i was treated this
way because of laws that were passed by
men
who have never been pregnant and never
will be says marlena stell founder of
makeup geek cosmetics
marlena stell recently spoke to cnn
about her gut-wrenching miscarriage and
how she was forced to carry her dead
fetus for two weeks
when a doctor refused to provide medical
intervention
due to the texas anti-abortion law
stella is a beauty youtuber and founder
of the cosmetics company makeup geek she
initially explained in a video last year
she and her husband were thrilled to
learn of the pregnancy noting that an
ultrasound at seven weeks was normal
however another ultrasound two weeks
later revealed stealth suffered a
pregnancy loss the doctor says there's
no heartbeat there's no viable pregnancy
following the news she asked for a dnc
which is a surgery to remove the fetus
also used to abort a living fetus this
was not a living fetus in order to avoid
infection or long-term health issues the
doctor said because of the new law
that's passed here you have to schedule
another ultrasound to verify that this
pregnancy is not valid before we can
give you any sort of medical
intervention
dr lillian shapiro an atlanta-based ob
gyn said to cnn carrying a dead fetus
can quickly become dangerous for the
mother
right but they're pro-life guys
they're all pro-life
so consider this situation imagine how
horrendous this is
it's not just
psychologically
disastrous walking around
with parts of a dead fetus inside you
that you're not allowed to have treated
the psychological impact but it's also
physically extremely dangerous and these
women are being is it too much to say
they're being tortured by republican law
doesn't seem like too much to say to me
she wanted to carry this pregnancy to
term and deliver it she didn't you know
the right loves to have this
almost at this point cliche borderline
satirical view of how women decide to
get an abortion well
it's month seven it's month eight it's
month nine i don't know i guess i don't
want it give me an abortion please that
that's an absurd fantasy but this is not
even someone who didn't want the
pregnancy this is someone who did she
wanted to carry the pregnancy to term
and deliver she miscarried and she was
denied treatment
because the treatment is the quote same
as that for surgical abortions
this situation uh ectopic pregnancy
we're also seeing it's like the entire
political party
never even took basic biology in high
school so we have
you know i i at this point we're two
weeks in guys since i told you
doctors are sounding the alarm
and saying they may be denying treatment
to women for fear
of being prosecuted for fear of not only
law enforcement
but politicians coming after them and
when i did that first story i got emails
from people saying david you're dealing
in hypotheticals david none of these
things are happening the hypothetical
about a 12 year old pregnant girl it's
merely hypothetical and then we got a 10
year old pregnant girl who had to leave
ohio and go to indiana to get an
abortion oh well now the issue's
different it's a fake story oh no but
the alleged rapist is an undocumented
alien so now it's a real story but
that's the only important part pathetic
and hear same thing oh no
just because a group of doctors warned
that this might happen doesn't mean it's
happening well now it is
now it is here is a specific woman
who was told
yes the fetus has died
but because of the law
the anti-abortion law you've got to walk
around for two weeks this way before we
can do anything and there's going to be
more of it
and the next layer in this
is
this is getting so absurd that even the
republicans can't defend it so the new
thing they're doing is they're playing
semantic games and the semantic games
that they're playing as they're saying
well
this procedure done
when there has already been a
miscarriage is not technically an
abortion and they're trying to hide
behind that as if this isn't the natural
effect of the law that they pass which
of course it is
horrifying
pathetic
and extremely damaging to the women
physically and psychologically and to
their families it's not just about the
women
what will we have for you tomorrow
i don't even want to know quite frankly
i'm sure it'll be horrible when i'm
looking for a good documentary i'll
sometimes scroll around on your average
streaming services and they're okay but
i almost always end up on an app called
curiositystream our sponsor curiosity
stream is the king of documentaries they
have only documentaries i recently
watched insect apocalypse it is
horrifying what's going on with the bees
extremely disturbing but the documentary
insect apocalypse is fascinating and i
can't recommend it more highly there's a
curiosity stream app for all of your
devices curiosity stream is always
adding new titles they have a ton of
awesome original content they have the
big award-winning documentaries by the
filmmakers we all know they also have
smaller independent documentaries that
are often just as good
on every topic under the sun and the
best part about curiosity stream is how
affordable it is you can get full access
for 14.99 a year not a month a year
that's a buck 25 a month when you go to
curiositystream.com
pacman and use the code pacman the link
is in the description